ein mann wird in ein haus geschleppt
offenbar einen krankenhaus kaum in der
lage sich selbst auf den beinen zu
halten
dieser mann ist ein afghanischer
journalist immer wieder erreichen uns
solche verstörenden bilder aus
afghanistan in den letzten tagen ja und
seit tagen ist auch unser reporter paul
ronzheimer in kabul vor ort berichtet
als einer der wenigen verbliebenen
westlichen journalisten über die lage
und dieses unfassbare leid vor ort und
er ist uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet live
aus afghanistan paul was kannst du uns
über diese neuen bilder berichten und ja
wie sicher seid ihr als journalisten
überhaupt noch
das sind bilder die gestern entstanden
ist und diese journalisten waren genau
dort wo wir gestern versucht haben zu
berichten wir wurden von den taliban
wütend weg geschickt haben uns dann
sozusagen auf ein haus begeben und von
dort weiter gefilmt und diese mutigen
afghanischen kollegen die waren noch
weiter offenbar auf der straße und
wurden dann von den taliban verhaftet
aber nicht nur das sie wurden
mitgenommen sie wurden mitgenommen auf
eine polizeiwache und dort dann aufs
brutalste
misshandelt wenn wir diese bilder sehen
dann erkennt man wie heftig die schläge
gewesen sein müssen die die taliban
ihnen zugefügt haben und so traurig es
ist muss man sagen offenbar sind
insbesondere die afghanischen
kolleginnen und kollegen für die taliban
wie freiwild bei uns bei den westlichen
journalisten also die die einen pass aus
deutschland haben oder aus den usa da
ist man noch etwas vorsichtiger aber die
afghanen die werden hier brutalst
mittlerweile geprügelt wir haben gestern
auch die bilder gesehen von frauen die
demonstriert haben die ebenfalls
geprügelt wurden von taliban scherben
muss man ja sagen
mutige frauen sind auch heute wieder
welche auf die straße gegangen
wir hören von einigen wenigen
demonstrationen in kabul aber die
regierung ist schwer nervös der
geheimdienstchef der taliban hat gestern
hier die
telekommunikationsunternehmen an anrufen
lassen hat mit ihnen gesprochen und
gesagt dass das internet in bestimmten
gebieten ausgeschaltet werden soll also
man hat hier durchaus große sorge dass
sich diese proteste ausweiten könnten
und dass die frauen nicht aufhören dass
möglicherweise weitere einen aufstand
gegen die taliban wagen die lage ist
völlig unklar in welche richtung sie
sich hier in kabul aber auch im ganzen
land entwickelt denn es gibt auch in den
provinzen proteste unter anderem in
herat da wurden zwei menschen erschossen
und das ist das große problem dass wir
hier in kabul journalisten wie ich sind
aber in den provinzen in afghanistan
viel weniger hingeschaut wird in diesen
stunden paul du hast uns gestern auch
darüber berichtet dass es eine neue
taliban regierung gibt die jetzt
gegründet wurde gibt es denn da schon
erste entscheidungen die durchsickern
es gibt keine großen politischen
entscheidung aber es gibt klare ansagen
an die internationale gemeinschaft
gerade hat sich der sprecher der taliban
regierung mudschahid den wir hier auch
im großen interview haben geäußert und
er hat gesagt dass es nicht geht wie die
usa über diese regierung spricht denn da
gab es gestern kritik natürlich an
dieser regierung weil mehrere auf der
terrorliste stehen und der
taliban-sprecher hat gesagt dass wende
sich gegen das so genannte doha
agreement also die damaligen verhandlung
die zwischen den taliban und der und den
usa der internationalen gemeinschaft
geführt wurden man will offenbar dass
jetzt diese minister die offiziell
ernannt wurden unter anderem hakkani als
innenminister der wird immer noch vom
fbi gesucht für zehn millionen dollar
gibt es für hinweise auf ihn so heißt es
zumindest offiziell man will dass die
von der terrorliste gestrichen werden
leider muss man sagen haben die taliban
hier immer noch erpressungspotenzial
denn es gibt viele amerikanische
staatsbürger die noch hier sind also
afghanischen einen amerikanischen pass
haben es gibt viele ortskräfte so der
amerikaner als auch der deutschen die
noch hier sind und das macht das
erpressungspotenzial in richtung der
internationalen gemeinschaft natürlich
groß paul du hast die ortskräfte
angesprochen die doch da sind nachdem
die bundeswehr abgezogen war war ja das
problem wer ist da überhaupt noch ein
ansprechpartner meldet sich irgendjemand
vom deutschen institutionen bei denen
hast du kontakt zu ort kräften zu die
für die deutschen gearbeitet haben und
gibt es solche kontakte oder werden die
tatsächlich zumindest für den moment im
stich gelassen
die deutschen oder die ortskräfte die
hier noch sind die werden im stich
gelassen ich habe mehrere kontakte zu
menschen die sich hier in kabul
verstecken allerdings gibt es eine gute
nachricht soll jetzt tatsächlich flüge
geben katar hat angekündigt dass man
fliegen will heute wird bereits einen
flug ein evakuierungs flug vorbereitet
dazu ist auch eine pressekonferenz
geplant also zumindest was den flughafen
angeht da kommt bewegung rein und das
würde natürlich auch hoffnungen bedeuten
für die ortskräfte für die menschen die
nach deutschland wollen die auch erlaubt
sind sozusagen nach deutschland zu
kommen dass es da eigentlich eine lösung
gibt
[Musik]